we all love Destiny's Child it's 18
here's Kelly and we were on the set with
you guys four independent women I want
to show you this real quick is funny oh
my goodness tell me what was what that
day was like and what was the funniest
thing that happened on set that day was
busy I don't know why but it's wrong
stick out to me for that video is if you
look to the left I believes the launch
is over to the left and there was a
model where the choreographers like
stand up on this moment and then do your
hands like this the launch goes her
emphasis on making it like that much
bigger of a movement was so cute because
her arms were like everybody else's arms
were here hers were like right she oh
she was filled with so much excitement
it was so cute she was like oh she's
like coaching you guys good I'd like
look at the energy
[Music]
oh my gosh talking about an independent
woman it just feels like that should be
a song that's out right now yeah it's so
many of the DC songs when you think back
on independent woman survivor how does
that reflect what we're living in today
you guys were ahead at the time it seems
absolutely I think that it's everything
right now I think that a lot of what we
are still going through overcoming as
women and I'm so proud to be a part of
such a historical record yeah especially
now when you watch the marches you see
lyrics being quoted on some of the the
huge banners and posters that everyone
has and you're just like this is
incredible this is a song that is how
old you know what I mean and it's still
so relevant and I don't know if that's a
good thing or a bad thing it's a really
good thing it's a good thing but you
also want us to evolve and progress so
yeah it's it's incredible to be a part
of such a record
[Music]
you know Charlie's Angels has a reboot
coming out and now they have a reboot
coming out so since you guys did
independent women the music video if
they came to you guys and said hey will
you do the the song for us would you
make a new song for them it's I don't
know it's something the ladies I mean
it's I don't know see what happens yeah
I mean that record has to feel special
that was the first time you guys were
officially a trio so does that hold a
special place in your guns because I
remember what that video felt like and
how it just felt like everything just
came together you know what I mean and
everything happens for a reason and it
was meant to be absolutely it was three
Charlie's Angels it was three of us it
was just God doesn't make any mistakes
absolutely not yeah and you know we've
been having these uh oh gee reunions
it was Beyonce and Latoya three-hit
Latoya I just started rocking it I
didn't see it that's so cute it's the
cutest photo but just speaking of that
with Latoya being pregnant and Michelle
getting married I mean how does it feel
seeing everyone grow up and they're
becoming mothers and wives and I mean
life has to happen you know what I mean
and that you watch it take place and I'm
just so happy that everybody has their
own little lives do you know what I mean
and I just actually saw Latoya at a
wedding and just watched her there with
her husband and I was just so happy for
her you know what I mean so it's it's
pretty awesome and Michelle is getting
married I don't want to show all of my
tonsils I'm so excited her and I
remember I was one of the first people
that she called and she put her hand up
and I was like what was yours and I was
actually in Australia and I just started
boohoo crying because he's such a Chad
her and Chad are just a romantic novel I
just love them okay so you approved that
it's no doubt that you know he's awesome
let's let's make it very clear chad is
awesome yes we love jazz speaking of
Michelle how she doing and how do you
support her with everything she's been
through so far she is
pun intended she is truly a survivor
truly a woman that is honest about her
emotions now and I'm just so so proud of
it all of us wasn't the same way
absolutely it took a lot of courage for
her to do that and I don't know if I
could but to share her story it just I'm
just so proud of her and I feel like
I've also watched her just grow as far
as like glow and grow yeah you know you
you watch other people watch her because
they're like I feel that I think I'm
going through that or or I've been going
through this and thank you for speaking
out and it's just her honesty is just so
admirable I love her so much we all bow
down to you guys when you came out on
Coachella and it just gave us the
reunion of our lives are you guys
thinking about going on tour at any
point and we talked about it we haven't
talked about no no everybody's you know
doing their own projects and things and
no that's nothing we talked about
you